-Our first guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
and writer you know from
her hit HBO series, "Insecure."
She both executive produced
and stars in "The Lovebirds,"
which is available this Friday
on Netflix.
Here's my conversation
with Issa Rae.
-Welcome back to the show, Issa.
How are you?
-I am doing great.
How you doing?
-I'm doing very well.
Do you have
a quarantine schedule?
Do you have a way
through the day?
-That's the only way
that I'm surviving.
I'm such a routine person,
in general.
So this has been like
heaven and hell simultaneously.
-[ Laughs ]
-So as long as I keep that
routine, I'm all right.
-Like a lot of people,
I've been listening
to a fair amount of podcasts
through this.
And I heard you on a podcast
called "The Rewatchables"
with Bill Simmons where you were
talking about "Groundhog Day"
is one of your favorite movies.
Do you feel as though
you're living through that now?
-Yeah, definitely.
I think -- you know, which is --
That's one of
the greatest movies of all time,
one of my favorite movies,
and it was such a treat
to talk about that.
But it is like you're waking up
with the same alarm
every single day, going to
the same parts of your house.
The only sad part is that there
are consequences for my actions.
-Yeah, of course.
[ Both laugh ]
Were you always --
Have you always been
a big Bill Murray fan?
-I have.
I mean, I grew up
on "Ghostbusters."
Yeah, he's just
always been a staple.
Seeing him on
"Saturday Night Live,"
obviously, he's just --
he's a treat.
-He is a treat.
Another treat
is Kumail Nanjiani,
and you guys
did this film together.
It was supposed to premiere
at South by Southwest.
Of course that was one of the
many things that was cancelled.
Now it's gonna premiere
on Netflix.
Can you tell us
a little bit about the movie?
-Yeah, the movie is about
a couple that is --
kind of reached a stagnant point
in their relationship
and are going out on,
you know, a night --
They're going on a night out.
And they are framed for murder,
like those things happen.
-[ Laughs ]
It's good, though.
Sometimes a couple
needs to be framed for murder
to appreciate one another.
-Just to spice things up.
Like, you know,
things get boring.
And I want to know
what you're like
when our lives are on the line.
-There is --
Theres a horse in the film.
This was not a real horse
throughout the course
of the film.
There was some
fake horsing happening.
-There was some fake horsery,
for our safety --
for Kumail's safety.
-Yeah.
-You know -- you see him, in the
trailer, gets kicked by a horse.
And I made sure,
when the real horse was there,
that I kept distance from it.
-I'm like you 100%.
I never feel comfortable
around horses.
I don't -- not even --
Have you ridden on a horse?
Is that something that seems
relaxing to you at all?
-No.
Relaxing? No.
I've done the side horse thing,
but even that,
someone was holding my hand
and guiding me.
But no.
Have you ridden a horse?
-Yeah.
I have ridden a horse,
and I hated every second of it.
And it's not --
I mean, like, I --
I just don't like that another
brain is in charge of my speed.
-Exactly.
And you're just supposed to
give your faith to this --
It's an animal.
-Yeah.
-And there's not even like --
You know,
there's no reasoning with it,
so it can do whatever
it feels like.
So it's horrifying.
-A lot of attention,
for my money, correctly so,
has been paid to the
transformation of Kumail,
who has for a long, long time
been one of
the funniest people working.
And then, he got cast
in a Marvel project
and now has the most
super-ripped body of all time.
I'm wondering if,
on set for this film,
which was before that,
he shot his Marvel project,
was Kumail very, I imagine,
conscious to what he was eating?
-He was conscious.
He had just started the journey.
And, to me, that's heaven,
because I'm a fad diet,
crash diet person,
so I'm always doing something.
So to meet a guy who was just as
food conscious as I was --
That doesn't mean I do well.
I just like
to try different things.
-Sure, and it's nice to have
a partner for that journey.
-It's nice to have
an accountability partner.
But he really just
took it to another level,
and I'm extremely jealous
of him.